core of the god butcher is granted a
wish for literally anything and he
doesn't think to save his daughter and
himself his choice isn't the only thing
in the MCU that has us confused
in Shang Chi and the ten Rings Katie is
a regular human with no superpowers no
combat training and no experience with
the supernatural her relative normalcy
frankly is what makes her endearing but
after she spends little more than a day
practicing archery with Guang Beau in
talo she displays Hawkeye level skills
in battle which would have been a little
easier to forgive if the film's entire
climax didn't hinge on Katie making a
one in a million shot that Nails the bad
guy in the throat after the movie Marvel
tried to explain this in the comics with
Sean Chi number 7 revealing that when
people go to talo they're given special
powers including super archery nice try
Marvel nice try
it was awesome to see Elena Grace the
screen in the Hawkeye TV series but the
reason for her appearance was quite
flimsy it all came down to a
misunderstanding if the characters would
have stopped hitting each other in the
face and simply had a conversation it
could have been sorted out in two
minutes rather than across six episodes
which was proven when they finally had a
conversation and sorted it out in two
minutes I'm sorry
supposedly Valentina made Elena think
Hawkeye was responsible for the deaths
of Black Widow so Elena spent the series
trying to assassinate Hawkeye only to
accept much much later that it wasn't
his fault what's weird is that the
events of Avengers end game appear to be
known to the general public as Kamala
Khan was able to describe the fight
pretty much play-by-play in Miss Marvel
so why doesn't Elena a highly trained
super spy know what everyone else in the
world knows it just doesn't make any
sense
at the end of one division Wanda defeats
Agatha by casting runes on the hex
barrier to prevent Agatha from using her
magic so long zagatha is inside the
circle of runes only Wanda can cast
spells however when Wanda allows the hex
to collapse Agatha should be able to
access her powers again only she
seemingly can't why screen Crush
theorizes that it doesn't matter if
Agatha is outside the hex because Wanda
cast a spell on her while she was still
inside the hex to trap her inside the
mind of Agnes once Agatha becomes Agnes
argues the sight she has no Free Will
and presumably can't cast any spells
still that explanation may not hold up
to scrutiny because of what Agatha had
previously told Wanda my thoughts are
not available to you tuts they never
ever were
if that's true then only Wanda's runes
seem to have had any real effect on
Agatha maybe when she returns in Agatha
coven of chaos we'll get the answers to
why she couldn't break free of one
dispel but don't hold your breath in the
first episode of what if the Red Skull
uses the Tesseract to create a portal in
hopes of unleashing a monster Captain
Carter manages to stop the creature but
not before passing through the portal
and getting stranded in the 21st century
however there's one small problem the
Tesseract doesn't work that way
canonically the Tesseract has been
established as something that can be
used to travel through space not time
that's why it's called the space Stone
yet somehow Captain Carter hurtles
through space and time ending up almost
70 years in the future if the space
Stone could actually allow the wielder
to travel through time then that would
have changed everything for instance
Thanos would have been much more
powerful when he held only two Infinity
Stones in the beginning of infinity War
but hey the series is called what if
after all maybe the Infinity Stones
operate according to different rules in
Captain Carter's universe
the world was in Jeopardy countless
times throughout phase four of the MCU
ranging from a celestial's emergence to
the newer Dimension nearly obliterating
Earth and more throughout all of this
where were the Avengers even if the team
itself is disbanded you'd think
individuals like Dr Strange or Wong
would have noticed Wanda's chaos magic
at Westview or Rhodey would have let Sam
Wilson a hand after seeing that the flag
Smashers were a real threat but nope
apparently they were all taking some
time off of course if the Avengers
showed up every time there was a threat
there wouldn't be much for Heroes to do
in their own solo films and shows
because of this the world was in danger
plenty of times before phase four
without the Avengers showing up just
look at Thor the Dark World and Captain
America the Winter Soldier but that's
the explanation in our universe and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it might be
nice if the MCU acknowledged that the
Avengers were at least paying attention
to all the crap happening in their world
sometimes by trying to resolve one plot
hole you create another case in point
eternals trying to explain why none of
them tried to stop Thanos from snapping
half the universe we were instructed not
to interfere in any human conflicts
unless deviants are involved but
attempting to offer an explanation for
the absence of the eternals only ended
up raising more questions the
non-intervention policy of the eternals
comes from their Celestial Masters all
they cared about was incubating their
new baby Celestial in the heart of
Earth's core here's the issue in order
to do that the celestials need the
population of Earth to reach a certain
point so having half of humanity snapped
out of existence would be a major
problem not to mention the fact that
Thanos might you know also snap half the
celestials out of existence too which is
also counterproductive maybe it would
have been better if the film didn't
mention Thanos at all because now that
we're thinking about it it doesn't make
any sense Dr Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness had madness right in the
title so it's easy to forgive any
details that don't make sense however
there is one plot hole for Multiverse of
Madness that's a little distracting
where's vision for the entire movie
Wanda seems to forget about Vision
instead she's only concerned with
finding Billy and Tommy from an
alternate universe once Wanda finds her
kids on Earth 838 vision is never shown
on screen even in the climax when Billy
and Tommy fear for their lives from the
Scarlet Witch Wanda 838 rushes to their
rescue while vision is nowhere to be
found not even the vision from Earth 838
there could be reasons why Vision wasn't
in this movie besides the prosaic
possibility that actor Paul Bettany had
a scheduling conflict but given that
Wanda's entire Arc in the MCU was
intertwined with vision it was weird and
disappointing that he was barely even
mentioned and Dr Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness
given they are Planet destroying
god-like beings who shaped the
universe's development you'd think
someone would notice the celestials but
nobody does unless the plot directs it
during phase three's Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2 for instance the celestial
ego almost consumed the entire Earth
without the Avengers even noticing in
fact this world-threatening event is
never acknowledged elsewhere in the MCU
then there's eternals which is even
worse although the eternals stopped the
new Celestial from fully emerging the
parts of the celestial that had already
sprouted from the planet's surface would
have still done cataclysmic damage to
Earth a colossal hand rising from the
Earth's mantle and bursting through the
ocean floor would be plenty sufficient
to wipe out almost all life on Earth not
only does the movie Never explore these
consequences but nobody seems to even
notice the gigantic Celestial protruding
from the ocean the barely averted
apocalypse has yet to be mentioned again
aside from a split second glimpse of a
news headline on Shield's laptop in
She-Hulk the biggest question about the
celestials if nobody in the MCU cares
about anything they do why should we
the climax of Thor love and thunder
gives the villain Gore a satisfying
Redemption rather than choosing to get
revenge on Thor and the other gods Gore
instead asks eternity to give his dead
daughter a second chance at life it's
very moving unfortunately though it
doesn't entirely make sense the movie
acts as though Gore only has two choices
wish to destroy all the gods as he
originally intended or wish his daughter
back to life even though he's dying from
a curse and won't be able to take care
of her but as far as the movie seems to
explain gork and wish for just about
anything the rules behind eternity are
hazy it seems like if Gore phrased his
wish more carefully he wouldn't need to
choose between saving his own life and
his daughters for one Gore could simply
wish to be reunited with his daughter or
he could wish that the drought that
wiped out his people never happened that
would mean his daughter would still be
alive and he would never have sworn
Vengeance on the gods ultimately the
film's emotionally bittersweet ending
would have felt more earned if it had
laid down some rules to the wishes
beforehand so any of it made sense
Doctor Strange has been repeatedly
depicted as taking his duties with the
utmost of fidelity even refusing to give
up the time Stone in Infinity War
despite it placing a Target on his back
so it was surprising when Dr Strange
agreed to cast a risky spell for Peter
in no way home especially because he
only seems to be doing it despite Wong
of course the spell backfired so instead
of making everybody forget that Peter
Parker was Spider-Man it summoned to
everybody who knew Spider-Man's secret
identity in this and other alternate
universes the whole disaster could have
been avoided if Peter and strange had
simply taken a moment to discuss their
plan before casting any spells come to
think of it it might have been a lot
more simple to cast a spell to make
people forget Mysterio instead and even
if Strange's spell hadn't blown up in
his space it still wouldn't have done
much good strange emphasized that his
spell wouldn't change history and would
just alter everyone's memories but
erasing memories wouldn't be enough
there would still be plenty of evidence
about Spider-Man's secret identity that
would would be impossible to ignore the
spell would be rendered useless as soon
as somebody Googled Spider-Man or
Mysterio or read an old newspaper or
watched an old news program simply
because the incriminating physical
evidence would still exist Doctor
Strange does ultimately cast a spell
that somehow succeeds in erasing Peter's
secret from the public record maybe he
should have used that spell the first
time
despite opinions to the contrary the
final episode of She-Hulk attorney at
law made sense Jen smashing through the
fourth wall was consistent with the
character and it was fun that Jen called
out the cliche of the bad guy turning
into a Hulk possibly be where this
season was going
the only problem was that The Season's
Hasty resolution left some confusion
about how much of what the show depicted
was real since Todd didn't turn into a
Hulk and Jen's alternate ending then
what exactly happened did Jen just call
the cops and Todd was arrested without
even a struggle with the cops even
believe Jen after she'd lost control At
The Gala for that matter what exactly
was Todd's master plan to Simply defame
She-Hulk also did the scenes with Jen
dating Josh never happened or just the
part where he steals her blood if Jen
wrote Josh out of the show completely
that would have huge repercussions
namely The crucial scene where Jen
attends Emile blonsky's Retreat would
have never happened it's not such a
stretch to imagine Josh stringing Jen
along just so he could film Jen sleeping
with him and released it at the gala to
humiliate gen still it would have been
nice to have the final episode at least
offer Clarity on which parts were real
[Music]